Let's go through the answers together.
We're looking for a space in "Ada Lovelace", and there is a space right here.
This "a" is at position 0, "d" is at position 1, "a" is at position 2.
So this space is at position 3.
Now we're looking for an "n" in "Alan Turing", and there are two.
The first one is at position 3, but here we're asked to start from position 4,
so the one we'll get is this last "n" at position 9.
Ada Lovelace is widely regarded as the first computer programmer.
In fact, she wrote the first computer program for computing some mathematics
before computers themselves even really existed.
They were just plans or blueprints.
Similarly, Alan Turing is often regarded as one of the leaders or founders of computer science.
The Nobel Prize in computer science is called the Turing Award.